Speaker 1: Well, Donald Trump has his first
serious challenger, I guess serious in the 2024
Republican primary. That challenger is former
South Carolina governor and Trump's own former
ambassador to the United Nations, Nikki Haley.
Nikki Haley was expected to announce any day.
Eventually, it became clear that she was going
to announce on February 14th, which is of course,
what is it? Is it like National Tea
Day or something? Valentine's Day.
Nikki Haley announcing she is indeed running for
president, releasing a three minute video, which
I have to tell you, I don't really understand
the case she's making for her own candidacy,
highlighting elements of her biography, but
appearing to say, I'm more or less like Trump,
but younger. See if you can figure out what is
the case she's making here. And then we're going
to talk about the outlook. We've got new polling
and we'll tell you where Nikki Haley is. It's all
getting very interesting. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: The railroad tracks divided the
town by race.
I was the proud daughter of Indian immigrants.
Speaker 1: Okay, so playing up racial
diversity, starting off with that.
Speaker 2: Not black, not white. I was different.
Speaker 1: It's enlightened centrism. She
wasn't black or white. She was Indian.
That's an interesting approach.
Speaker 2: But my mom would always
say your job is not to focus on the
differences, but the similarities.
And my parents reminded me and my siblings every
day how blessed we were to live in America.
Some look at our past as evidence that America's
founding principles are bad. They say the promise
of freedom is just made up. Some think our
ideas are not just wrong, but racist and evil.
Nothing could be further from the truth. I
have seen evil in China. They commit genocide
in Iran. They murder their own people for
challenging the government. And when a
woman tells you about watching soldiers throw her
baby into a fire, it puts things in perspective.
Even on our worst day. We are
blessed to live in America.
I was born and raised in South Carolina.
So I've seen the very best of our country.
People here threw out the old tired political
establishment and demanded accountability for
their tax dollars. Industry reports
called us the beast of the Southeast.
Which I love. People came by the thousands
for fresh start. Moms and dads held their
heads up high. Children learn that it was always
a great day in South Carolina. It's a great day.
A great day. A great day. A great day in South
Carolina. We were strong. We were proud. And when
evil did come. Police in South
Carolina are looking for a.
Speaker 1: Gunman following a shooting at
a church. Yeah, that when when evil came,
they did nothing about gun safety. The
victims, we don't know the severity.
Speaker 2: We turned away from
fear toward God. Right. Values.
Speaker 1: That's true. They did nothing
about the guns. And they said we need prayer.
Speaker 2: Make our country the freest and
greatest in the world. We must turn in that
direction again. Republicans have lost the
popular vote in seven out of the last eight
presidential elections. That has to change.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, maybe better candidates
and better policies would help.
Speaker 2: Joe Biden's record
is abysmal. But that shouldn't come as a surprise.
The Washington establishment has failed us
over and over and over again. It's time
for a new generation of leadership.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so it seems to be basically she's
Trump, but a new generation, meaning younger.
Speaker 2: To rediscover fiscal responsibility,
secure our border and strengthen our country,
our pride and our purpose. Some people
look at America and see vulnerability.
The socialist left sees an opportunity to rewrite.
Speaker 1: By the way, the socialists
on the screen are Nancy Pelosi,
who is known for stock trading. Joe Biden,
a center left Democrat. Kamala Harris,
very much not a socialist. And Bernie, who while
describing himself as a democratic socialist,
actually really runs as a social Democrat. This is
the best they can do when it comes to socialists.
Speaker 2: China and Russia are on the march.
They all think we can be bullied, kicked around.
You should know this about me. I don't put up with
bullying. And when you kick back, it hurts them
more. If you're wearing heels. I'm Nikki Haley.
Unidentified: And I'm running for president.
Wow.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So Nikki Haley is running for president. If
I understand correctly, it is the standard,
completely generic, boring, old right wing
talking points combined with She's younger and
she's Indian. I mean, that's quite frankly, that's
my understanding of what she's saying here. Now,
it will be interesting to see Trump's reaction
as of this moment. Trump has not responded to
her challenge of Trump's Republican primary and
looking on truth social here. So I don't see that
Donald Trump has posted anything. So we'll
see the direction that this goes. There is
a new Morning Consult poll out from this week.
It has Nikki Haley polling 3%. Of course, this
poll was taken before she announced her candidacy.
We'll see if maybe she could get to 4% or 5% based
on this announcement right now. That tracker has
Trump at 47, DeSantis at 31, pence at seven. And
Nikki Haley tied for a heavily contested fourth
place with both Liz Cheney and Ted Cruz. So very,
very exciting numbers for now for Nikki Haley.
The primary is truly starting earlier than ever.
I mean, it is February. We already have multiple
candidates, by the way, February not of 24,
but of 2023. One of the practical questions that
comes up is do these candidates even really start
campaigning yet? Donald Trump really hasn't. Other
than that, one very low energy event, by the way,
in South Carolina and putting out some really
strange policy proposals that are not really
policy, they're kind of more complaints. We'll
see if Nikki Haley starts campaigning regularly.
This is you know, if we think of July of
next year or even August, probably July
as as the end of the primary, we are talking here
about a 17 to 18 month stretch of primary. We
already have two candidates. It seems implausible
that they're just going to be aggressively
campaigning starting now. But maybe the fact that
it's not just Trump running anymore is going to
force some of that to get going. So, Nikki Haley,
if you wanted if you're on the Republican side and
you don't like Trump, you now have someone
who is actually running, actually running,
losing very badly to Ron DeSantis, who hasn't
even announced. But it is it is at least an
official candidate. Let me know whether you
think Haley will make any sort of impact here.